-I´m glad to have you here.
-I´m so glad to be back.
I had so much fun last time!
-I had so much fun
last time, too,
which is why I was taken aback
by something.
-Oh, boy, what?
-Saw you did an interview.
-Uh-huh.
-They asked you what five people
would you have
at a dinner party.
-Okay.
-Martin Luther King.
-Yes.
-Your grandmother.
-Mm-hmm.
-Katt Williams.
-Ay!
-Future husband.
-Hallelujah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then your fifth person
was Jimmy Fallon.
-Mm-hmm!
[ Screams ]
[ Laughter ]
Well, Seth, you know
I got love for you.
We will make room for you
at that dinner table, okay?
-Oh, that´s very kind of you.
-I will make sure of it!
-All right, thank you so much.
You know, let´s just make it
a six-person dinner party.
Then we don´t have to worry
about the rest of it.
-Yeah, we´re good, we´re good.
-I´m so happy you´re here.
Congratulations on another
season of the show.
-Yes.
-I know people love
the show so much,
they will yell "Taystee"
out to you on the streets.
-♫ Taystee... ♫
all the time.
I get it all of the time.
-I hope they --
but they don´t
all sound that beautiful.
Their voices are not that good.
-Yeah, normally nobody sings it,
but yeah.
-But you have a -- you also
gave yourself a nickname
back in the day.
This was something you did
to yourself on purpose.
-I did. And it was not smart.
I mean -- so when I was
auditioning for colleges,
I auditioned
for a lot of schools.
And one of the first ones
was Minnesota and Guthrie.
-Uh-huh.
-The Guthrie program.
-So these were theater schools.
-These were theater schools.
-You´re coming from
South Carolina.
-17 years old.
-Uh-huh.
-It´s, like, 40 people
all in a room, standing up,
saying their name
and where they´re from.
And it started to get boring.
So I was like, "You know what?
I´m going to stand out."
My ass decided to stand up
and say,
"Hey, y´all,
my name is Peaches!
I´m 17 years old and I´m from
Greenville, South Carolina!"
-[ Laughs ]
-Yo, and....
I was like, "Okay, I´m just
kidding, it´s Danielle."
And it took -- from Guthrie --
because it´s mostly the same
theater kids --
from Guthrie to Juilliard,
where I attended,
these people were calling me
Peaches for a year.
[ Laughter ]
I kept saying,
"It´s not my name.
It´s not my name!"
So Taystee, Peaches --
all of it just sticks.
-Yeah. I mean, I will say
it´s tough for those people,
because you explicitly
said it was your name.
-I did.
[ Laughter ]
False advertisement.
I did. Yes, it was my bad.
-So that -- you know,
I imagine the pressure
of auditioning for those theater
schools, in a way, prepares you
for auditions
the rest of your life.
Because that seems so intense
and you´re so young.
-Yes.
-When you auditioned
for Taystee...
-Uh-huh.
-...you really went for it
there, as well.
-[ Clicks tongue ] All the way.
I was, like, kind of --
what do you call it?
Um, I just...
jumped into the role.
-Uh-huh.
-So in the description,
it said,
"Don´t wear any makeup,
make sure that, you know,
you look like an inmate.
[ Laughter ]
So I decided -- it also said she
wore a muumuu, so I was like,
"You know what?
I´m going to just pick
the biggest shirt I have
in my closet."
And I remember going
to the audition and having,
like, a pair of pants.
And I was like, "You know what?
I think I´m-a have to take
these pants off."
[ Laughter ]
And like -- so it could
look like a muumuu.
It was like a long...
-Yeah.
-...shirt dress thingy.
Took it off
and, like,
did my little thing, you know.
I cornrow´ed my hair back
and sang a little Chaka Khan.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I got the job.
-Oh, there you go!
[ Laughter, applause ]